A technical and progressive explanation
of the study of movement. We'll start
with a truly comprehensive technique. This
technique isn't necessarily intended to
have a martial or other explanation;
it allows us to work on
different technical points and solutions
in response to a
challenge. One of the kochinags we can
work on is a kochinag that
allows us to enter directly and,
from there, to throw the opponent.
So its aspect will be interesting in
relation to the angle
of entry. Many people will say, "
Yes, if they release, what happens?" and so on.
And we'll enter the study of the
essi, which is an interesting study
from the moment the practitioner
has acquired enough technique to
be able to work on the movement and
not just on the technique itself.
So, from the moment
I enter, I've worked on my
different technical points, and
now, if they release from this
movement, I can continue.
And a second technique,
Viord, we'll position ourselves at this angle. The
movement I started, Avein,
will continue
here with a variation of the
C of prayer technique. You'll
work on the movement to be able to
use another technique.  You
have already
studied, and if you are not at a distance to
return, and if you don't have contact,
we will continue
from there. We will position ourselves
at this angle,
and if I pass kochinag, it releases. And
if I am not at a distance to make
contact here, then I will be able to
continue my movement and
continue. The study of progression
will move from a technical study of
moroteori and
kochinag. You will be able to
study one kochinag among others on
the moroteori stimulus,
or use different techniques to
study the movement. And then, from
there, I initiate my movement; it could
release me at any
moment, but I will continue my
movement. And of course, the choice of
these three techniques
is only three among many others.
You could use or call upon
numerous techniques from your
repertoire and your knowledge. Hence
the importance of starting the first
step by learning many
techniques and then linking them to
the study of movement.